I had a first question I'm gonna adjust
my first question because we saw it
there at the end of the credits
how many IndieGoGo contributors oh boy I
don't 600 it's a lot but I when I see
that wall of support it's it's pretty
formidable and I think it's something
that how would have loved that's what I
thought too that those are you know you
don't you don't give money to make a
documentary about how Ashby unless those
movies meant something to you they spoke
to a lot of people I mean and also just
the you know in the last sort of last
scene where he's talking about you know
like I want to I want to have a studio
where all I do is you make movies and
have my own control I was like he's you
know it could have been something like
that you know like crowdfunding would
have blown his mind I think as a
democratized system production yeah he
would have he would have liked that
so everybody who you put up there on
screen and I'm sure many of the people
who got cut out and many of the sound
bites from the people who are included
that got cut out like I I expect to see
in a documentary I know how Jane Fonda's
gonna sound I know how Jon Voight is
gonna sound they're gonna salute Lou
Gossett some people I know Lee grant who
are gonna say really by the way I'm Ben
mankiewicz um host to Turner Classic
Movies sorry no that doesn't matter um
so that's why I know these people um and
but who I did not expect to see in
documentary and who sort of blew me away
with everything he said and the way he
said it was a Cat Stevens so that
couldn't have been an easy process to
get him to agree to be in this talk no
it was hard I mean with all these guys
all these people it was a matter of just
getting to getting through to them you
know and which everyone can do
eventually you can find your way in and
then they sort of go oh you want to talk
about how like my old buddy how and you
can tell the the joy that they all
experience or they light up or they get
really emotional
so like you said there was there was a
cast of characters like I knew I know
these guys I know Norman's gonna say yes
you know like but cats T wasn't such a a
Hail Mary we're like let's just try and
and when he said yes I mean we were we
were blown away and and and then just
sort of sitting in a room with him like
eventually I was I was starstruck you
know every time I sat down with someone
although I got better and better it kind
of being cool with it but not with cat
it was really but it's also there's a
responsibility that comes with
interviewing him because it doesn't it
just doesn't happen no very often I mean
I I'm gonna embarrass myself in front of
you guys now but I told you backstage he
started talking and I was like he's
English yeah like you know I'm not alone
some of you were like oh yeah that's
right
because we just haven't heard from him
in so long so you had a connection
through his band but still what do you
think made him say yes to this when he
clearly says no to so much else most
everyone I just think their bond the
relationship that that how and cat had
was so intense and special and and I
think that he's always you know reserved
a place for him in his heart and he
wanted to talk about his friend
incidentally we we had these t-shirts
designed and said ash be an artist named
Jeff Rotter made them so he brought a
shirt you know so Dorking out here's the
shirt and he got really excited and he
loved it and then he ended up hiring her
to do all of his tour merchandise so
it's so cool music meant a great deal to
Hal it means a great deal in his movies
so Heather there was a you know I mean
there's always a challenge when coming
up with a score for a movie but there
was a different kind of challenge here
yeah given house reverence yeah I mean
he's such a musical guy you know like
and I've loved his films for so long and
I'm familiar with how he sort of placed
things and his thoughtfulness and and
just him as this consummate artist you
know like that I feel like this was a
really special process it was kind of
lightning fast
but at the same time we went so deep
with it you know is a really emotional
process and I feel like that really
spoke you know we're groovin out and
writing all these cool little like
hammond organ stuff and playing a lot of
upright bass and doing all that stuff
but i just really wanted to serve the
art the same with that same passion that
that he did hopefully on some level and
it was great during some of our early
screenings to know that people that knew
him felt that we did a pretty good job
hopefully you know it felt really
important for us
you killed it it was it was a beautiful
score I was blown away yeah and it was a
lot of pressure and a lot of
responsibility and no time I mean we
thought we meditated on this film for
like six years but then when it was good
finally go time there was a lot of
sleepless nights on your end so you say
six years what was the that was the
ruminating part how long did you spend
ruminating and then once and what what
enabled you to get going
and and completed I mean this is an
independent documentary so they there's
no money money was just rolling in no so
I was editing you know I was doing side
work and I was busy having kids and it
just took a it took that was my snake
that was yeah this is my first child and
I had to in the process and yeah I mean
we I had like so Cory I had this pitch
like treatment and I'd carry that around
and try you know try to talk obsessively
to anybody that would listen to me about
this idea years ago and you listened
very early on and we approached the
estate and I think they thought I was
crazy because I hadn't made anything yet
I was just like I'm going to make this
and they finally bought in or I didn't
go away one or the other and you know
then we crowdfunded so we just kind of
took it in stages and crowdfunding only
paid for you know X amount of production
but I because I'm an editor I knew I was
like I'll just edit when the kids take
their naps and at night and it might
take me two years and then it took like
five but uhm yeah it worked
it's cobbled together so
did you have a particularly discouraging
moment once that process began one
discourage well what was the most oh my
gosh I don't even know where to start I
mean it was a constant I thought I was
losing my mind I mean you go through the
stages it's like grief denial excitement
whatever and your friends are just
asking about the project year after year
you still working on that
we got rejected from every grant that we
applied for we had financing that was
several times the somebody's gonna come
through with this financing and then
would follow through after months so
yeah I don't know where to begin
I was kind of I wasn't sure what was
gonna happen I accept that we're gonna
finish it I know that you did know that
there was not a moment where you thought
we're done no no no no that was never an
option for how like once we started we
were gonna finish I just didn't know how
long it would take so the obvious
question is is why I think I know the
answer but why Hal Ashby why why for you
and then why for you rather why why is
this something you wanted to be involved
in I read I've always been a fan of his
films and obsessed with that era of
filmmaking and in general there's
something about the way that he treats
dialogue and it's there's just a gentle
hand that he has and so when I was
editing films um I always kind of had
this like what would how do you know
like Ashby wouldn't make some goofy
montauk it's like there's ways that you
can kind of okay yeah check yourself and
I did that for years and when you were
editing you would literally think well
yeah well my whole life yeah what would
he'll do and then I when I was
interviewing people it was both with
Studs Terkel do so those two were my my
lake lighthouse figures but and then you
know I read I read a book about him and
I couldn't believe that there wasn't a
film I was googling it to rent it and it
wasn't there so I worked at a video
store for a really long time and I
played in a lot of bands at the same
time in Athens Georgia and uh so many of
my music friends that
Mette were through house films like so
many people like if someone would come
up to the counter and rent like being
there you know the list you know like
had the stack and be like friend you
know like it's like this immediate
kindred sort of community that you just
have right out of the gate and I've
always sort of felt that way about those
films and I feel really fortunate to be
able to do you know that he rented the
last detail to me like in the 90s 2001 I
remember that did you were you guys
friends
that's a beautiful film you know thank
you it feels important you said you you
google that eyelash B documentary and
you couldn't get it well now you can get
it